l'oxygène à voilà ce dont manque
cruellement le népal ces derniers jours
comme son voisin indien
le pays subit depuis quelques temps une
explosion des quatre corps navires us
cette semaine elle cinq personnes sont
mortes d'asphyxié à l'hôpital au népal
à la question de l'oxygène est devenu
une priorité alors que le système de
santé local est encore plus précaire
qu'en inde la gestion de l'oxygène à
notre principal tension la direction de
notre hôpital a fait de son mieux pour
éviter la pénurie d'oxygène nous
disposons de 40 lits dans une unité
d'urgence dont cinq sont équipés d'une
alimentation centrale en oxygène aimait
les 35 autres ont besoin de bouteilles
d'oxygène à katmandou la capitale
les hôpitaux sont saturés annonce ne
plus pouvoir prendre en charge les
nouveaux malades
pour le chef de la fédération
internationale des sociétés de la croix
rouge
le népal manque cruellement de moyens
c'était déjà assez tendre vous le co
lead et maintenant vous êtes un stade de
rupture ils ont besoin de personnes
formées ils ont besoin de personne des
bruits qui travaillent davantage 24
heures sur 24
ils ont besoin de ressources humaines
pour exécuter et ils ont également
besoin d'équipement vous avez besoin de
plus d'oxygène de bouteilles d'oxygène
vous avez besoin de techniciens pour
être en mesure de sauver des vies
premier producteur mondial de vaccins
l'inde a gelé ses exportations au mois
de mars pour pouvoir gérer la situation
à l'intérieur de ses frontières
le népal elle se tourne aujourd'hui vers
la chine qui lui a livré cette semaine
400 bouteilles d'oxygène et près de
800000 dos de son séromantique ovide
sinopharm lundi le gouvernement a lancé
un appel au monde en demandant d'urgence
de l'oxygène est des équipements de
soins intensifs et des vaccins si
personne ne venait à répondre à l'appel
le pays se dirigerait vers une situation
terrible a géré selon le ministère
népalais de la santé